Caption: [Applause]
Caption: all right hello everyone uh normally I'd
Caption: like to be in the crowd a bit more but
Caption: I've been told because of the banner and
Caption: the microphone I have to stay behind the
Caption: lectern uh I'm Karen Larry I'm talking
Caption: about their people not users uh the only
Caption: thing I really you really need to know
Caption: about me for this talk is on the main
Caption: slide and that's I'm a graphic design
Caption: lecturer I currently teach sessionally
Caption: at Murdoch University uh teaching in the
Caption: graphic design degree so if you do have
Caption: graduates come through that don't know
Caption: what they're talking about that's
Caption: probably my fault
Caption: um
Caption: so I'm just going to give a shout out to
Caption: all the sponsors that make today
Caption: possible as well as all the volunteers
Caption: and the committee members who are giving
Caption: their time to put together this great
Caption: conference for us
Caption: so today what I want to talk about is
Caption: human centered design and this is a term
Caption: that's actually coined by Don Norman Don
Caption: Norman wrote a really great book called
Caption: the Design of Everyday Things that I
Caption: highly recommend
Caption: and he says the goal is to produce a
Caption: great product one that is successful and
Caption: that customers love it can be done
Caption: though this is all about empathy which
Caption: is something that we are familiar with
Caption: many from ux design and we're looking
Caption: here at putting people first we're
Caption: looking past the visuals but unlike what
Caption: we see in ux design we're actually also
Caption: looking past the functionality to focus
Caption: on the thoughts and the feelings of the
Caption: people who are using your app and your
Caption: product
Caption: so how do we do that
Caption: well most of the time we'd start with a
Caption: Persona so let's meet Ben Ben is a
Caption: software developer here in Perth he's
Caption: married he doesn't have any kids he's
Caption: got terrible taste in music and he
Caption: enjoys rock climbing and running as his
Caption: two Main Hobbies
Caption: once we've written our Persona we might
Caption: make some scenarios and chances are once
Caption: we've written those scenarios the
Caption: language that we use to talk about band
Caption: changes
Caption: we might find we start using words like
Caption: user like visitor click subscriber
Caption: traffic customer the language goes on
Caption: these words are actually quite
Caption: problematic because they focus
Caption: themselves on the role of the user when
Caption: they're using your product we assign a
Caption: role to them based on that interaction
Caption: and based on how we intend to profit
Caption: from them
Caption: Don Norman who I mentioned coined the
Caption: term Human Experience design is actually
Caption: the one who coined the term user
Caption: experience design
Caption: and he developed what we call human
Caption: Center design because he also thought
Caption: these words were quite problematic
Caption: because Ben is none of those things
Caption: Ben's a person
Caption: so the first thing that we really need
Caption: to be doing here is changing our
Caption: terminology and calling our audience
Caption: people
Caption: they're not users they're not visitors
Caption: and they're not clicks this is a really
Caption: small change that we can be making in
Caption: our internal documents in our company
Caption: but it actually allows us to refocus our
Caption: team on what's important and that's this
Caption: big messy complicated experience that we
Caption: call being human and the fact that your
Caption: app's only one small part of that
Caption: because let's face it being human is
Caption: complicated just look at Ben Ben screws
Caption: up a lot
Caption: do you really think you can account for
Caption: all of the different ways Ben manages to
Caption: screw up on an almost daily basis
Caption: Ben is lazy
Caption: Ben doesn't like having to get up in the
Caption: mornings he'll often leave for work at
Caption: the last possible moment he's
Caption: unpredictable not even his wife can
Caption: sometimes predict some of the behavior
Caption: that he manages in the decisions that he
Caption: makes he's very complex like most of us
Caption: Ben will often believe in contradictory
Caption: things at the same time and get a very
Caption: heated arguments about them
Caption: Ben also wastes a lot of time he'll
Caption: spend a lot of time on his phone
Caption: browsing Reddit
Caption: a lot of time watching TV
Caption: when we use language like visitor like
Caption: user we are suggesting that there's a
Caption: such thing as an ideal user for our app
Caption: and there is no ideal user that doesn't
Caption: exist we don't know the situation Ben's
Caption: going to be in when he uses our app we
Caption: don't know the environment we don't know
Caption: how he's going to be thinking or feeling
Caption: so we really need to be thinking about
Caption: how we can change this terminology and
Caption: think of Ben as being human because if
Caption: we don't do this Ben's going to find our
Caption: app really frustrating to use
Caption: and when Ben gets frustrated when he
Caption: does screw up
Caption: it's not Ben's fault Ben's very good at
Caption: blaming other people it'll always be
Caption: your fault as the designer
Caption: a way around this as I tell my students
Caption: when I'm teaching is to ask why
Caption: you want to ask why five times is a
Caption: guide that I give my students and we do
Caption: this because human error is never the
Caption: answer if the answer you've come up with
Caption: is that it's Ben's fault you have to
Caption: keep digging because Ben will not accept
Caption: the blank
Caption: you need to look beyond the feature that
Caption: Ben's gotten stuck at and look at the
Caption: problem with the system itself
Caption: because Ben cares about a lot more than
Caption: your product
Caption: so we need to look beyond the product
Caption: itself beyond the features that you've
Caption: developed
Caption: Ben himself he cares about climate
Caption: change he's quite concerned about the
Caption: world he's very aware given he's a
Caption: developer about how his data is being
Caption: used and about the kinds of commissions
Caption: that he's granting the apps that he uses
Caption: Ben's much less likely to use your app
Caption: if it's not ethical
Caption: now I'm going to put a little asterisk
Caption: here because human-centered design
Caption: doesn't have to be ethical and we see
Caption: plenty of examples that aren't
Caption: but human-centered design is about
Caption: focusing on the experience and creating
Caption: a positive experience for people using
Caption: your app so it should always be ethical
Caption: and when we're talking about ethics what
Caption: we're really talking about is the
Caption: respect that you have for your users
Caption: people are more aware now than ever
Caption: before thanks to shows like the social
Caption: Dilemma on Netflix about the social
Caption: responsibility the people making their
Caption: media should have
Caption: so the very first element we need to
Caption: consider when we're talking about ethics
Caption: is human rights making sure that you
Caption: protect the fundamental human rights
Caption: that your app has so when looking here
Caption: about your social responsibility at the
Caption: very core
Caption: you want to make sure your app is
Caption: transparent accessible and sustainable
Caption: so you don't want to deceive users a
Caption: really good example of this is the
Caption: Twitter Bluetick
Caption: when we see a blue tick on Twitter we
Caption: often see it as holding some kind of
Caption: power we see it as representing a status
Caption: symbol of power and recognition no one
Caption: has really exemplified this more than
Caption: the way people have reacted to Donald
Caption: Trump on Twitter before he got banned
Caption: the Blue Tick actually just recognizes a
Caption: high profile user it stops other people
Caption: from impersonating them that's all that
Caption: does but the decision that Twitter made
Caption: to use a tick as a symbol very much
Caption: changes the reaction we have as an
Caption: audience to that symbol
Caption: we want to also be transparent in an
Caption: upfront about the purchases people might
Caption: need to make in our products we know not
Caption: we've all heard of microtransactions EA
Caption: games made the news a few years ago in
Caption: 2018 2017 over microtransactions
Caption: the microtransaction industry is still
Caption: massive
Caption: in 2021 it was worth 60 billion dollars
Caption: so there's definitely a lot of money to
Caption: be made here but is it ethical EA Games
Caption: had developed what they called loot
Caption: boxes as a way to advance faster in
Caption: their games we saw Belgium in 2018 ban
Caption: these loot boxes as a form of gambling
Caption: that actually got overturned briefly and
Caption: it got overturned Because the actual
Caption: legislation that defined what gambling
Caption: is didn't cover this form of in-game
Caption: purchases in apps but while the law
Caption: wasn't really up to speed and still
Caption: isn't in many countries around our use
Caption: of microtransactions
Caption: it doesn't make it ethical do we really
Caption: want our kids and our teens in these
Caption: apps potentially with your credit card
Caption: making these uh purchases and learning
Caption: from a really young age to gamble rather
Caption: than putting in the effort for gameplay
Caption: your product should also aim to reduce
Caption: inequality which is a really important
Caption: aspect of Human Rights this comes down
Caption: to learnability thinking about how easy
Caption: it is for first-time users and also that
Caption: dreaded word that I'm sure we all find
Caption: frustrated with at times compatibility
Caption: making sure it works backwards across
Caption: different devices
Caption: our next element is respecting human
Caption: effort so your app should be functional
Caption: it should also be trustworthy and
Caption: reliable you want to respect the effort
Caption: that we're actually putting into using
Caption: your app
Caption: so you want to respect privacy here you
Caption: want to only collect information from
Caption: your from the people that are using your
Caption: app that's absolutely necessary to be
Caption: using it we are more aware than ever as
Caption: I said about the kinds of permissions
Caption: that we're granting when we use apps
Caption: you also want to think about the extent
Caption: to which you as a designer or a
Caption: developer are actually going to
Caption: influence the behavior of the people who
Caption: use your app a really good example from
Caption: of this comes from a book called stolen
Caption: focus by Johann Hari this book looks at
Caption: the different ways that our attention
Caption: spans have actually reduced and it just
Caption: looks at ways Beyond just technology and
Caption: Beyond social media but it does have
Caption: understandably quite a few chapters
Caption: about social media and in it Johann
Caption: talks about the creator of the scroll
Caption: feed
Caption: and says that the creator of the scroll
Caption: feed actually deeply regretted his
Caption: decision and being a part of this
Caption: creation and it did what it was supposed
Caption: to it allowed kept people on on the app
Caption: it kept people there for longer allowing
Caption: them to collect more data sell more ads
Caption: and make more money but it didn't
Caption: respect effort that people were putting
Caption: into being in that app
Caption: We compare this to Netflix
Caption: Netflix after you've watched a few
Caption: episodes gives you a notification asking
Caption: if you're still there it is thanks to
Caption: this notification that Ben makes it to
Caption: bed on time at night
Caption: so the last aspect we've got is where we
Caption: really see this link with human-centered
Caption: design and that's creating positive
Caption: experiences this is about the emotional
Caption: connection people have with your product
Caption: it should be delightful it should be
Caption: intuitive and it should be invisible if
Caption: your app works well I shouldn't notice
Caption: the interactions I'm having in it it
Caption: should be that easy to use if I'm having
Caption: to think about it you've done something
Caption: wrong
Caption: now we can't consider ethics without
Caption: also considering the wider Community
Caption: because Ben is part of the bigger
Caption: Community our design has to focus on the
Caption: entire activity under consideration not
Caption: just the smaller components you have and
Caption: this is a reason why we all have terms
Caption: like feature creep in our terminology
Caption: Ben is part of a much bigger system than
Caption: your app he's part of the software
Caption: Community here in wa and in Australia we
Caption: need to be sensitive to the history and
Caption: the culture and the beliefs of the
Caption: structures in the community that we're
Caption: designing for and you can't do this on
Caption: your own even if you have a team of
Caption: people whose job this is you cannot do
Caption: this on your own you need to be talking
Caption: to the community that are going to be
Caption: involved in your app
Caption: which means you can't just talk to Ben
Caption: Ben is very privileged Ben is white and
Caption: male Ben has no ongoing health
Caption: conditions Ben's got a full-time job
Caption: with a good salary Ben has a bachelor
Caption: degree he's paid off his hex debt
Caption: something I'm sure not many of us can
Caption: say and Ben is heterosexual and married
Caption: being people-centered means you have to
Caption: consider all of the people who are
Caption: involved if we use Healthcare as an
Caption: example this means the patience this
Caption: means the doctors the families the
Caption: general practitioners Specialists
Caption: technicians nurses the list goes on you
Caption: need to think about everybody in that
Caption: community
Caption: now how do you actually do this well
Caption: there's obvious Solutions with
Caption: connecting with stakeholders doing field
Caption: interviews setting up meetings and going
Caption: out and observing in the different
Caption: Industries and this can be costly
Caption: I'd like to note here that it's not as
Caption: costly as spending a year developing
Caption: something that the community doesn't
Caption: actually want
Caption: but you should also consider the ways
Caption: you can use your current channels to be
Caption: engaging in this process
Caption: for example I always have an open
Caption: Communication channel that I invite
Caption: stakeholders to and I can really quickly
Caption: and easily drop in issues that we're
Caption: having questions we might have and keep
Caption: the community on board with the progress
Caption: we're making in the app and those
Caption: decisions that we're making so you could
Caption: even be thinking about here how can you
Caption: repurpose the the technology and the
Caption: systems already available to you that
Caption: might mean making a dedicated channel of
Caption: teams for example where you can invite
Caption: some key stakeholders for me this part
Caption: of the process is really important and I
Caption: couldn't develop any work without having
Caption: that open Communication channel with the
Caption: stakeholders involved
Caption: so I simply put we want to learn about
Caption: the people that we're designing for and
Caption: then we want to take time to make sense
Caption: of what we've learned and I've got this
Caption: as a separate point because we don't
Caption: want to come in with assumptions about
Caption: who Ben is because Ben's very
Caption: unpredictable he'll surprise us
Caption: we then want to look at opportunities
Caption: for how we can Prov improve people's
Caption: lives and we want to do so ethically
Caption: only then should we start prototyping
Caption: while maintaining contact with our
Caption: community stakeholders
Caption: now some of you have caught on Ben is a
Caption: real person he's my husband and he's in
Caption: the front row here so let's all thank
Caption: Ben
Caption: I'm not quite sure how I'm going for
Caption: time if there's any time for questions
Caption: and Ben is uh in uh on just after me by
Caption: the way in the main theater so that's
Caption: been running off to get ready for his
Caption: talk and Ben will be talking about
Caption: offline mode offline first not offline
Caption: mode uh in the lecture theater
Caption: God yeah
Caption: great talk uh congratulations uh for Ben
Caption: good sport
Caption: um uh any tips on how to affect change
Caption: within an organization on using
Caption: inclusive language people when it's so
Caption: ingrained in in that culture absolutely
Caption: so this can be probably the toughest one
Caption: I find uh simply so I write a lot of the
Caption: reports myself and I'll actually use
Caption: inclusive language in the reports that I
Caption: am making so I very much try to push
Caption: that from the point of view of the same
Caption: as when I'm in the classroom being the
Caption: one that's making the change and setting
Caption: that example there's other Solutions
Caption: such as actually getting Community
Caption: stakeholders in so I find that well that
Caption: can be quite costly it can be really
Caption: effective when people are being told
Caption: about the importance of inclusive
Caption: language from the people who are
Caption: actually affected by it looking at
Caption: Healthcare as a an example bringing
Caption: people in who actually suffer from
Caption: disabilities and talking about the way
Caption: some language impacts them can really
Caption: change people's Focus because it stops
Caption: it from being an abstract term and
Caption: that's the issue we have with language
Caption: these terms they just feel really
Caption: abstract we don't connect them to people
Caption: when you're actually faced with the
Caption: people you're using this terminology for
Caption: it can be enough to start pushing for
Caption: that change
Caption: any other question
Caption: thank you so much well thank you
Caption: [Applause]